ça laisse une impression d'improvisation
de part et d'autre et jamais on a
vérifié on est remontés 50 ans en
arrière
jean charest est officiellement la
première belle-mère libéral au québec en
politique une belle-mère ses 15 nancy
enchère critique publiquement son succès
semble beaucoup plus habitués à les voir
se manifester dans le camp péquiste
avons juste les élections de 2012
alan pauline marois était à la tête du
pq avant les élections bernard landry a
publiquement critiqué la stratégie des
péquistes
c'est une illusion totale par avant les
élections jacques parizeau a préféré
soutenir jean martin aussant et au front
national au lieu du pq je vais respecter
les décisions du sectarisme et après les
élections quand le gouvernement marois a
adopté la charte des valeurs mais sur
parizeau bouchard et landry sont tous
sortis publiquement pour un critique et
le contenu au fond des choses ça
pourquoi tiens parce qu'on veut
légiférer là dessus du côté libéral jean
lesage robert bourassa claude ryan et
daniel johnson fils ont toujours gardé
un devoir de réserve
et si quelqu'un connaît les effets
potentiellement dévastateurs que peuvent
avoir les commentaires d'un ancien chef
c'est bien jean charest en 2003 monsieur
charest avait brandi en plein débat une
déclaration de jacques parizeau fait
quelques heures plus tôt sur l'argent et
le vote ethnique
êtes vous en train de nous dire que vous
êtes d'accord avec sa déclaration
regrettable soirée du référendum qui est
en train de répéter aujourd'hui mais
monsieur landry qu'une manoeuvre qui a
complètement déstabilisé qui venu hanter
leurs rêves la campagne de bernard
landry mondiale terrain par thème
[Musique]
geoffrey